hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga and we've left it off uh uh
some some time ago uh during the morphe
not during after morphy's um uh well
suddenly ended match against daniel
harvitz and the question is what happens
now in the morphe saga i know a lot of
you guys were interested in this where
is morphe going next and what is
happening next what is happening with
his match with staunton will it ever
happen who will morph face next uh and
so on and uh we're gonna discuss uh all
of this but uh first i would just like
to mention that this game has already
been shown on this channel it is uh the
most famous
is morphe against the gamepl charles of
brunswick and count is art uh and uh it
is also known as the opera house game it
is uh such a beautiful game that um it
should be shown all the time i did a
video on it some four years ago i think
maybe even more maybe five but i will
put a link to that in the description
below it will be the first thing you
will see so there uh it's gonna be
there's not a lot of analysis on this
game because it's been analyzed so much
but if you want you can check out that
video as well uh there's only the game
there and it's also a nice way to see
how maybe the channel developed over the
course of maybe some five years uh but
uh we're going to get to the game but
first a little bit about um uh how
things led up to this game so morphe
finished his match with harvey so the
the match
did not uh not all of the games were
played uh but after you know harvest had
a sort of a successful start to the
match morphe then uh just obliterated
him and after the match morphe wanted to
organize another chest another match
against harvest harvest was not
interested but uh he was constantly
playing constantly playing in cafe de la
regence in paris and um
uh he simply was not interested in
another match and later on uh harvest
even organized a blindfold simultaneous
exhibition against eight opponents just
to show everyone that he is as good as
morphe uh but those games were well not
of the same caliber because uh you know
it is said that people just left pieces
on pre you know uh it was it was too
easy for for harvest to win those games
so harvest kind of orchestrated the
entire thing and even though uh he was
also uh well he he had a chess column of
his own where he would publish you know
everything that was happening in the
chess world he would publish games none
of the games from his blindfold
simultaneous exhibition were actually
published there so it wasn't really um
at that you know on the same level as
when morphe did it and uh
he was basically banished from cafe de
la reshanza and then he had to leave
france and uh he also went back to
london now uh regarding the match with
stanton if you remember when we started
this whole stunt and saga you know he's
been avoiding morphy first when he met
morphy then he said all right we're
going to play a match but
let's you know just give it give me like
a month to prepare and then after a
month um morphy again send a letter to
staunton and he said what about our
match and then staunton did not reply he
just left birmingham for the birmingham
chess meeting uh and he said that he was
going to play there and then morphy also
left the birmingham uh
he did not play he said that okay uh
maybe if i'm just going to be late then
i'm not going to enroll in the
tournament because if he arrived there
in time it would be too difficult for
him not to enroll in the tournament so
their first uh
stauntons uh you know tricked morphy
into waiting a month then he tricked him
into waiting uh for the uh birmingham
chess meeting to finish and then when
morphe again confronted him publicly uh
staunton said that all right we will
start our match uh in november and
morphy said all right uh i can wait
until then i'm gonna go to france i'm
going to go to paris i'm going to
challenge all of
uh the the the greatest players there
including mr harvest uh that we've shown
uh you know a lot of previous videos uh
in the saga were about the harvest match
uh and now morphy again uh sent a public
letter to staunton uh regarding their
match and he said that please you know
pick a fixed date as i did not receive
any sort of a reply uh and uh yeah he
didn't just send the letter to
staunton he sent it to all of the
publishers and he wanted all of them to
publish it as well and all of them
published it except
staunton's chess column uh and then
staunton replied to morphe in private
and in in that letter he stated that
basically he never actually agreed to a
match uh he agreed to a match uh if uh
time allowed it and that he's very much
into other work in the literature into
everything that his publishers are you
know at his back all the time he he
didn't he wasn't getting enough sleep he
was fatigued he was uh well basically he
was ill and that he will not be able to
play this match and this went on for
quite a while uh there's quite a lot to
read about it if you guys are interested
it would take too long in one video uh
but you're welcome to
uh grab the the book on morphe the the
the joints are of chess uh by lawson uh
to check it out if you guys wanna uh you
know dive into this thoroughly and uh
interestingly um there was a a coin was
coined uh after his uh match in um uh
after his matches in paris and his
victory against harvest uh it is said
that uh uh well the american medalist
george h lowett made the made the coin
it said that the observed side of the
coin had a likeness of morphe while the
reverse read he has bit beaten harvest
in chess uh chess playing in staunton in
courtesy and everyone could agree on
this but morphy did not want
the public to think that uh
you know his match with stanton not
being held uh had anything to do with
him and staunton was constantly using
his chess column to make it appear that
way even though in his private letters
to morphy uh he stated otherwise but
morphy stopped replying to his private
letters and the morphe wanted everything
absolutely everything to be made public
then they started saying that okay
morphe had no backers uh he didn't have
seconds he didn't have uh you know uh
money ready
none of which was true okay morphe
didn't really have backers but he said
that if that was the problem you could
go to any chess club the saint george's
club he was well received there uh that
he would easily find any backers and
regarding the money for the match there
was uh everything was settled well up
front and of course staunton knew this
uh and i i think the the agreed price
was some uh 500 pounds uh but he said
that if stanton required more than they
they would go higher
but as you know that time went on time
went on uh it was pretty clear to morphe
that the match with staunton will never
happen but it was still uh really really
tricky because
[Music]
staunton's chess column was very very
popular and really had a lot of
influence and then when morphe uh when
staunton published his letters he
published more of his letters as a reply
to staunton's letters he sometimes
didn't publish the entire letter that
morphy sent only you know bits of it he
would leave out something and then it
would sort of seem like uh it was
staunton who's in the right maybe not
not morphy so much and that maybe it
wasn't all of staunton's fault that the
match didn't happen and as his chess
column was so popular then uh it was
basically uh his uh
writings that that reached the united
states and you know the the the rest of
the chess world so that was a pretty big
problem but uh everyone made sure and
everyone you know who was involved
involved uh really understood that it
was not morphe's fault and that it was
all
um at the fault of um
uh well uh howard staunton that that the
match didn't happen so like i said
there's really a lot to read about this
you know every letter every every letter
of the letter is you know
recorded so really do get the book you
you're gonna enjoy it and interestingly
morphy ended every letter uh to the
staunton as uh your very humble servant
paul morphy so he he had a lot of
respect for for staunton as he was older
and as morphy said uh when they first
met when they were first approaching the
you know arrangements of their uh
competition uh that uh
he was honored that uh such such a
distinguished player such as howard
stanton would even meet him over the
board and he was always very polite even
though morphe of course knew that he
would probably beat him but uh you know
yeah you never know he he never showed
that publicly and he always had a great
respect for howard staunton uh but yeah
that's pretty much it for for this um
uh saga of uh not meeting staunton even
though we kind of said it it was all
leading up to the match with staunton
but the match never happened and it's uh
well it's just uh terrible and you know
uh definitely a sour bite to end the
meal as philip sargent says in his book
on morphe so ends what we can what can
only be regarded as a melancholy chapter
in english chess history uh and it
definitely can so uh as morphe
understood this he still had some time
in paris uh before you know deciding on
what to do next who he will challenge
next and uh he was really really
respected in paris now he tried to
arrange another match with the daniel
harvest of course he he would not have
it uh and then he started playing other
matches then at some point more morphy
just started giving the odds of a pawn
and the move or even two moves sometimes
too to everyone and he still still kept
beating everyone he started meeting some
very famous people some you know uh
princess princesses uh dukes counts as
you'll see in this game and okay
sometimes he he let them win sometimes
he defeated them uh you know if playing
more prominent people he would often end
the match in a draw
such were the times but all in all he
had a good time and he was he was a
superstar there he was basically a god
uh there's even a mention of him uh
visiting uh
uh
sort of a theater and with the entire
orchestra that was playing there uh you
know uh stood up and saluted morpheus as
he entered and he didn't even notice
this as they say
so you know laurels could be said about
uh his trip and you know his endeavors
in in paris but uh now we return to our
game that we already shown on this
channel like i said it will be the first
link in the description below so now
we're going to show it again for those
of you who are new to chess and maybe
don't enjoy watching older videos but
i'm i'm not going to analyze it as much
as this game is all about enjoyment so
uh this was played during an opera
uh and it's still not decided which
opera was it it's uh it's sort of a
general agreement that the opera was the
barber of seville uh but there are some
others that uh
are possible but the morphe didn't
really enjoy this as he had to be turned
with his back uh you know from the opera
so he couldn't enjoy the opera while he
was playing this game and the two
gentlemen here uh uh played uh you know
as they do against him there is a
mention of a third person being involved
but not i didn't find any uh sources
that he was actually suggesting in any
of the moves so here paul morphy faces
duke charles of brunswick and count izor
and it is uh well in my opinion the
greatest chess game ever played uh you
know okay there's of course the
evergreen game there's the immortal game
there's you know there are a lot of
beautiful games but this one uh to me at
least is the is the greatest game ever
played so without further ado let's
check it out and enjoy it for some of
you the first time for the rest of you
will uh
you can always enjoy this one so morphe
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 to do a replies with e5 we have
knight to f3 and d6 going for the
philidor's defense uh we have d4 and now
the move that has been uh you know uh
analyzed uh ever since and nowadays we
know it's a bad move but in those days
of course uh such a developing move
there didn't seem to be anything wrong
with it so bishop the g4 bobby fischer
also scolded this move thoroughly in his
uh you know analysis of the game as it
allows the whites to just you know take
advantage of the position right away and
that is exactly what morphe does he
plays d captures on e5 and now the
problem with this idea is that black
cannot recapture if black recaptures we
just trade queens captures captures
white wins upon attacks the bishop
attacks f7 and already white's position
is
well
in morphy's hands more than winning but
in most other players hands also winning
so after the captures on e5 black is
forced to
trade his bishop for a knight here which
also allows white to just rapidly
develop his pieces so bishop captures
knight queen captures bishop already we
have a queen developed now black can
recapture a pawn but now bishop to c4
already morphy is threatening checkmate
so what do you do here black defense
knight to f6 but now morphy plays queen
to b3 uh yes moving the same piece twice
in the opening but with great threats
the f7 pawn is attacked and the b7 pawn
is attacked so black needs to defend on
f7 we have queen to e7 and now comes the
so-called uh uh
artist not a butcher move morphe plays
knight to c3 uh morphy of course could
capture on b7 and then threaten the rook
here but this allows black queen to be
for check and here black would just
trade queens and the morphe uh did not
want to go this and
hence uh morphe is is an artist not a
butcher so here we have knight to c3 now
queen to b4 uh does not come with check
uh and you have to you know pre prepare
what to play so here we have c6 now the
queen guards both f7 and b7 so the queen
cannot capture on b7 and not bishop to
g5 every move morphe plays here is uh
either developing or sacrificing or or
just straight out winning
and black plays b5 now he wants to get
rid of the bishop from this diagonal
here but now is the time to strike there
is no time to go back there is only one
good move here and of course you guys
know which move it is since you've
probably already seen the game and that
is knight captures on b5 black is
completely undeveloped and uh well we're
just not going to give him time to
develop so c captures on b5 uh you could
go queen to b for check now but it's uh
not not much better for example queen
delivers check we trade queens captures
captures and we play c3 and that's it if
c captures uh on b5 we're going to
capture with the check pick up the
bishop later and we're up to pawns so
we're we're completely winning here so
uh the duo cannot allow this they accept
the sacrifice and now bishop returns to
b5 with check and now what do you play
here uh well going to d8 or something
like that runs into
queenside castles with checks so not
really something you want to
go for so knight b to d7 now you're
going to play rook here you're going to
move the queen develop the bishop and
maybe castle and so on of course that's
not going to happen but that's what
black is planning so here morphe
castle's queen side and again a move
with tempo attacking the knight here
because this knight can never move so
capturing here will be deadly so black
needs to bring another defender here we
have rook to d8 and now comes rook
captures on d7 just eliminating
everything and preparing to bring our
last attacker into the game rook
captures on the e7 and now rook to d1 so
what can black do here our next movie is
just capturing on d7 there's no
defending this uh and the knight will be
unable to capture due to the pin here so
uh here black says all right i'm going
to move the queen so now the knight will
be able to capture and then i'm going to
develop there should be seven castles
and so on uh but morphy played bishop
captures on d7 with check knight
captures on d7 and even though most of
you have seen this game uh feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
morphe in the greatest uh uh you know
imaginable way while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh
you know spectacular move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's queen to b8 with check that's the
good stuff and the black king has no
squares the bishop controls this
diagonal and the only move for black is
to capture the queen with the knight so
knight captures on b8 was played and
then now comes rook to d8 and here we
have the opera house checkmate uh it's
not called that really i just call it
that but you know if you deliver this uh
at any point uh you know in your life do
know that this is the opera house
checkmate uh it has to you know follow a
queen sacrifice of course otherwise it's
just a very nice checkmate
uh so this is uh
well one of the greatest games ever
played in my opinion the greatest game
ever played it's simply a masterpiece
it's you know it deserves a place on you
know
every wall every you know refrigerator
you know every living room uh you know
it should every book should start with
this game and uh well for those of you
who have seen it for the first time hope
you guys really enjoyed it but also do
check out the video i made on it some
some five years ago um so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
morphe is now uh looking for his next
opponent and who will it be well it's
hard to say uh but he has his eyes set
on uh well the probably the actual
strongest player in the world not
counting morphy of course and that's not
howard staunton uh that's actually out
of anderson the creator of the first
immortal game and the the gentleman who
created the evergreen game the the
gentleman who played so many beautiful
games and he's really the the original
chess romantic uh
if you haven't seen the the immortal
game or the evergreen game i will also
put links to that those games in the
description below it will be below the
uh opera house game that i've made five
years ago so three links in the
description below uh do check it out the
videos are a bit older but it's uh you
know kind of nice to uh to check it out
and uh morphe okay now he will finish
this game he will see what else is there
to be done in paris but then he is off
to braslaw uh which is a rothslev today
but uh there he will try to face adolf
anderson and hopefully he will be more
successful than in his endeavors here in
uh uh london trying to face uh howard
staunton
uh so that's the game uh and uh hope you
guys really enjoyed it and this
concludes our howard staunton saga i
know it didn't end how many of you hoped
for but uh you know it's uh as sergeant
philip sargen says one of the greatest
tragedies in english in english history
uh so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank tom daralo
alexandra trebus brendon fukuda arnie
fox and job charmario uh for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day